Okay, I think we're now ready to
derive a parallel version of BFS.
To summarize,
let's recall the two big ideas.
First, you should carry out a BFS
level by level, not vertex by vertex.
Secondly, you should process
an entire level in parallel, so
remember, why does this work?
Essentially you perform the same
action on every vertex of the level so
the order in which you visit
those vertices shouldn't matter.
So here's a high level pseudocode
that embodies these two big ideas.
Now it looks almost exactly like
the sequential algorithm but
there are two really
important differences.
First, the algorithm
is level synchronous.
Notice that there's a level counter and
there are these level-specific
frontiers, F sub L and F sub L+1.
Now since this loop is going level by
level, the span, as defined by the while
loop anyway, ought to be no more
than the diameter of the graph.
Now to implement the second idea,
I've hidden everything in this
function called process level.
We're going to have to say more about
how you actually implement this thing.
But essentially what it does is it takes
the graph and the current frontier, and
it'll produce a new frontier.
It'll also update
the distances of course.
Now to actually make all of this work,
we have to say, what is the data
structure that we can use for f?
And for that,
I'm going to tell you about a special
data structure called a bag.
Dun da da da, super bag.